Okay.
Big News, uh, after weeks, really two months
of this back and forth, former special prosecutor
Robert Mueller.
It
is going to testify before Congress and as
far as we know right now it's going to be
public and it's going to be televised and
it's going to be huge right now.
The date is July 17th.
Robert Mueller is going to testify before
to house panels, the judiciary and the intelligence
committee panels.
Uh, this is according to the respective chairpeople
of those two committees and I hope that enough
time is actually allocated for this that Robert
Mueller can be questioned in depth.
And to refresh your memory, in his nearly
450 page report, Robert Mueller said he could
not exonerate Donald Trump from obstruction
of justice if he could have exonerated Trump
on the basis of his investigation.
He would have said it in clear and, and certain
terms which he did not.
And in fact, Robert Mueller's report once
you got past the propagandizing of it, including
through the bar letter, which we'll talk about,
the report actually said there was significant
evidence of obstruction meeting all three
legal requirements of obstruction in eight
of the 14 different possible obstructive acts
into which Robert Mueller looked.
Now, what we don't yet know, uh, is whether
Robert Mueller ultimately agreed to this public
testimony under threat of subpoena because
we had every indication that Robert Mueller
did not want to testify and that he had been
resisting testifying.
He wanted his statement from a few weeks ago
to be all that was said.
In addition to the report itself, Robert Mueller
actually saying the report is my testimony
and clearly that was not good enough for Democrats
in the House and Senate.
And rightly so.
Then it became clear that Robert Mueller would
accept testifying if it were private behind
closed doors and not televised.
And Democrats again said it should be public
and it should be televised, rightly so.
And now it will be time to see what does Donald
Trump do to try to obstruct or distract from
or get in the way of these hearings.
And of course to distract from the content
of the hearings as well.
And there are a few different lines that are
being pushed on this from the Trumpists so
far as of right now as a, when we're taping
the show today.
And this may have changed by the time you
listen to or watch this segment.
Uh, Donald Trump has not activated around
this news in any way.
Um, but from what I've been seeing from Trumpists
in the normal right wing Trumpist of the Internet,
there's a few different talking points that
are being repeated ad nauseum.
Number one is simply nothing is going to come
of this period and nothing notable is going
to be said by Robert Mueller, uh, repeating
that Robert Mueller already said his full
investigation is in the report.
There's nothing else to be said by Robert
Mueller.
Uh, the talking point that Robert Mueller's
has to find is going to help Donald Trump
win reelection in 2020.
And that Democrats are stupid for doing this.
The word nothing burger is being repeated
frequently.
And like with everything else, we just have
to wait and see.
I mean, that's it.
If we've learned anything from the last however
long we've been following politics and corporate
media reporting on politics, it's that we
need to wait and see what actually happens.
They said all along the Trump is did that
the Mueller report would have nothing in it.
Uh, although you had some strategic people
like Rudy Giuliani saying, oh, we, we expect
it could be bad in order to sort of, uh, pad
the landing so to speak.
But the hardcore Trump is too, we're not working
directly for Trump are saying the Mueller
report is going to have nothing.
And in the end, the Mueller report ended up
saying he can't exonerate Trump.
There is substantial evidence of eight counts
of criminal obstruction.
Huge Andy Muller testifying publicly on live
television is also going to be huge.
If you thought that Michael Cohen's testimony
was a big event for the world of Cspan and
the like, Robert Mueller's testimony is going
to be orders of magnitude bigger than that
and we do not know what is going to be said.
What we do know is that before the Mueller
report came out, the Trump campaign, the Trump
administration, the Trump, uh, inner circle
ran this massive dis information campaign,
which included at its sort of center as its
centerpiece of the bar letter itself, which
was a complete and total misrepresentation
of the content of the Mueller report.
They're going to do it again.
Okay?
No matter what Trump is, we'll say Mueller
is not a credible person and they will attack
molar personally.
They will say after the testimony, Mueller
either brought nothing serious to the table
or if he claimed to bring something serious
to the table, Mueller was lying.
And that's why the character assassination
in advance will be key to this strategy laying
the groundwork.
And we know this in advance, so we have to
remember not to be influenced in any way by
what these Trumpist actors say.
They will attack.
Molders, there's credibility no matter what.
They will go after the process of the investigation,
no matter what.
They will continue to demand counter investigations
either into the investigators or into Hillary
Clinton or some into Barack Obama.
They want investigated.
So we should be setting realistic expectations
and I'll talk about that in a second, but
we should not be paying even one iota of attention
to the predictable talking points that we're
going to see from the Trump pissed.
Right.
So as far as the expectations go, it's not
likely that Robert Mueller is going to reveal
anything substantively shocking related to
the results of the report.
That's not in the report.
But that doesn't matter because the entire
point here is most Americans have not read
the report.
When I have advocated for an immediate start
to an impeachment inquiry in the House of
Representatives, it's not because I believe
it will get Trump removed from the White House,
from the Oval Office more at all, or certainly
not more quickly than just voting him out
in November of 2020 the issue is that many
American's perception of the report is what's
in the bar letter.
The no collusion, no obstruction talking point
circulated by Donald Trump's national exoneration.
Two are on which he went after the bar letter
was published.
And by having one day, hopefully multiple
days of hearings with Robert Mueller will
confirm and restate what's in the report,
which will be news to most Americans.
That in itself will be a huge win because
it will inform people of the content of the
report.
Something most Americans do not know about,
some because of deliberate ignorance, some
because they're just busy living their lives.
And so this is why in the same way that an
impeachment inquiry would be extraordinarily
useful merely by publicizing the content of
the Mueller report, Mueller testifying, we'll
hopefully do the exact same thing.
So that's the news as we know it.
As of right now, by tonight, this may even
be different.
Uh, but we will have more coverage of this
as we get closer to July 17th.
Good news overall.